après les chevaux une barricade de métal
des voitures gouvernementales alignés le
long de la frontière mexicaine pour
empêcher les migrants haïtiens d'entrer
au pays ce sont des mesures sans
précédent affirme le gouverneur du texas
nous arrêtons et emprisonnant toute
personne qui traversent la frontière
illégalement dit greg abbott grands
supporters de dans notre champ
pédoussaut mur joe biden a complètement
échoué sa politique migratoire ajoutent
ils il affirme que le texas va
dorénavant prendre les choses en main ir
il ce minois contre les passeurs
plus de huit mille haïtiens seraient
toujours sous le pont international
certains ont été emmenés aux états unis
en autobus il serait soigné par des ong
d'autres expulsés vers port au prince
certains n'avaient pas foulé le sol
haïtien depuis plus de dix ans depuis le
tremblement de terre de 2010 ce n'est
pas encore clair comment se fait le tri
on tient les médias à l'écart le
gouvernement byden temps de régler le
cast et haïtiens le plus rapidement
possible
l'image de l'agent d'immigration talent
un cow-boy prônons la soa migrants
haïtiens a fait le tour du monde et
soulevé une véritable onde de choc le
discours de joe biden d'un retour à la
dignité pour chaque migrant sonne de
plus en plus faux 2 to address
avengers
ces images ne reflète pas qui nous
sommes lancés alejandro mayorkas
secrétaire à la sécurité intérieure à
ciudad acuna au mexique il continue de
traverser le fleuve rio grande et pour
aller aux états unis des familles femmes
et enfants tentent le tout pour le tout
pour une vie meilleure car chez eux en
haïti s'il désespoir et à partir de
demain 7 vols pour haïti sont prévues le
gouvernement américain compte doubler le
nombre de renvois soit 1000 personnes
par jour en haïti on craint que cette
crise migratoire vient de s'ajouter à la
crise humanitaire que vit déjà le pays
il s'est fait voler leur guise
radio-canada del rio texas